once upon a time in a faraway land
actually not that far away just in your
tv screens
there lived all your favorite fairy tale
characters sorta have you ever imagined
what it would be like to see all your
favorite fairy tale characters come to
life would elsa still have ice powers
and would captain hook still be evil the
hit abc series once upon a time actually
reimagined all of our disney faves in
the real world
let's just say comparing them to their
animated selves gets pretty shocking
prepare yourselves snow white defeated
the evil queen
i did not see that coming from classics
to new 2000s hits
once upon a time did not discriminate in
fact they covered one of the hottest
disney princesses to date the one and
only elsa of arendelle
like her animated twin the elsa in the
series had her classic ice cold braid
blue dress and a personality that could
humble literally anyone
while she got to keep her looks and
magical ice powers elsa wasn't the queen
of once upon a time
in fact her whole story in general was a
little different she was trapped in a
magical urn and had her memories wiped
after both her and her sister anna
discovered that their parents had
actually been researching how to strip
their evil aunt ingrid of her ice powers
so in the end elza in once upon a time
was still the princess we all loved but
just with a darker added twist
how can you say these things we promised
we'd never be like this
once upon a time couldn't have done a
frozen arc without the bubbly princess
or should we say queen of arendelle anna
like her sister she is literally an
exact replica of her animated self
except
well real but her red hair and her
engagement to kristoff is where those
similarities end
like elsa her story is a little
different than the classic tale
disney spins she along with kristoff
were put under a curse and stuck in a
crate in the ocean by their evil aunt
ingrid
luckily elsa along with emma were able
to save them once upon a time
actually really focused on princess snow
white while the real-life version played
by jennifer goodwin
might have had the same black hair kind
face magical singing voice and seven
house guests
she was also a warrior let's just say
she could rival katniss everdeen with a
bow and arrow
you've probably guessed that this means
her story is a little different from the
original we all love and you're
absolutely right
she's actually one of the reasons why
the evil queen became well
evil that's why she spends the majority
of the series on the run from her
stepmother and her minions the evil
queen curses her
prince charming and the rest of the
kingdom to the real world in the cursed
town of storybrooke
snow white is actually a lonely grade
school teacher you might be wondering
how exactly snow white managed to make
the evil queen evil
and we have the answer for you the evil
queen also known as regina mills
although wealthy grew up with a kind
heart like her father
she even saved snow white from a
terrible horse riding accident
but she kept her secret love the stable
boy from her mother
when snow white outed her regina's
mother cora ripped out his heart and
killed him in front of her
i mean we kind of don't blame her for
going evil do you
she spends years trying to capture snow
white for revenge and even took on the
same powers as her mother removing
people's hearts and killing them or even
controlling them
she still uses her classic magic mirror
and creates a poisonous apple
stop denying who you are snow white
when you think of rapunzel the first
thing that probably pops into your head
is flowing blonde hair that is too long
to even imagine having in the real world
in once upon a time
her appearance might originally be
similar to the rapunzel we've all grown
to love
but she actually ends up doubling as
lady tremaine from cinderella
also known as the evil stepmother so in
this rapunzel story
it's safe to say we got more of a mother
gothel type lady
like we mentioned before prince charming
marries snow white in this series
instead of cinderella while his
appearance is you guessed it
charming and he is very noble and his
backstory is anything but traditional
in fact he's actually an identical twin
as a baby
his brother was whisked away to be
raised by a king and he was left to be
raised on his mother's farm
but when his brother is killed he's
kidnapped by the king to take his place
well i'm impressed ariel she just wants
to be where the people are and the
mermaid princess in once upon a time was
no different
this red haired couldn't wait to grow
legs and be with her prince eric forever
but before that could happen
things got a little dark there may not
have been a flounder in this film but
there was an ursula
using a potion the sea goddess had given
to her she got a magical night with
prince eric but the evil queen who was
on the hunt for snow white
tricked ariel into thinking she was
ursula she gives ariel legs forever and
turns snow white into a mermaid
but once upon a time ariel was a true
strong independent woman and stabbed the
evil queen before she can get away once
upon a time ariel seems like she'd be
one heck of a best friend
but can you keep a secret i'm a mermaid
so we never really got to see ariel
interact with the real ursula but that
doesn't mean she doesn't exist in the
world of once upon a time
she looks a lot different than the
animated sea witch and her story is way
better ursula actually starts off as a
mermaid but after being tricked by her
father and captain hook to give up her
beautiful singing voice
she transforms herself into a green sea
monster in order to take reign over her
father and his kingdom
wild right ursula you can call me your
majesty
once upon a time kept this character
stunning beauty wardrobe and love for
books
but her story again is intense compared
to the original
she actually trades herself willingly to
become the maid to a beast
in order to protect her family during
the kingdom's ogre wars
she of course falls in love with the
beast just like the films but gets
whisked away by the evil queen's curse
she forgets all her memories and is
locked up in a mental asylum
and you're rude how is the beast like in
once upon a time you ask
well he's definitely a beast the beast
in this series also takes on the role of
rumpelstiltskin
and the dark one he was cursed with the
darkest magic in order to protect his
son from going to war
the dark magic also came with a tendency
to be evil and some pretty gross
leathery skin
unlike the movie though his love for
belle is unable to break the dark one's
curse
doesn't mean they still can't be
together right captain hook didn't just
have a part in ursula's story he played
a huge role in the series and actually
managed to become one of the core
characters you might be imagining the
classic permed black-haired lame pirate
that you saw in the original peter pan
movies
but this captain hook is actually a huge
vibe or maybe it's better to say a hot
fibe
his real name is actually killian jones
like many other villains he actually
started off as an innocent and kind
orphan who fell into the ranks with the
wrong crowd
as a pirate he fell in love with a woman
named mila who happened to be the dark
one
also known as rumple's wife he clearly
didn't take that too well
because captain hook lost his hand and
mila her life
since that moment hook has called rumpel
the crocodile
get it and swore to one day kill him for
what he'd done
killing me is going to take a lot more
than that dearie we have warrior
princess mulan
jamie chung does an amazing job bringing
this animated character to life and
appearance wise
she's basically identical in the series
she's actually the protector of princess
aurora and prince philip
but there's a twist she's also in love
with aurora we know we didn't see it
coming either but how
iconic is that why are you smiling at me
meredith might belong to the other
studio but once upon a time still
managed to sneak her into their
storyline in season 5.
in the show she still has the same fiery
red hair medieval blue dress
and an attitude that no one wants to
cross she's also never seen without her
bow and arrow and is still titled as a
hero for saving her mother
and 3. annoying but adorable brothers
from her curse
you saw what i can do with an arrow do
you really want to see what i can do
with a sword
it was a whole new world for jasmine
when she left agrabah
to come to storybrooke in search of
aladdin and a way to save her kingdom
once upon a time knew they had to be
super accurate when it came to including
princess jasmine
she looks almost identical to her
animated version although she had many
different outfits
we still saw the princess in her
traditional dresses you might be
wondering why we didn't really mention
peter pan when talking about captain
hook and that's because hook wasn't the
villain in that tale
in fact he was the victim that's right
peter pan is a villain in once upon a
time
and unlike some other evil characters he
doesn't really have a forgivable
backstory
he's just evil he created neverland and
took over the island's magic in order to
selfishly stay young forever
as for the lost boys he tricked them
into believing they'd have a better life
on the island
but instead of paradise it was more like
constant war there are some similarities
between pan and his animated version
they're both young elfish and wear green
we don't have any kings in neverland
just me while disney has given us so
much incredible content throughout the
years there's no doubt that they've also
left a lot of room for creativity and
imagination
which comparison was the most shocking
for you who was your favorite disney
character versus once upon a time
character
share all your magical thoughts with us
in the comments section below don't
forget to give this video a thumbs up
and hit that subscribe button
see you in the next kingdom